hi everybody can you all hear me
great so hi my name is Ethan Rosenthal
I am a data scientist at DIA in Co here
in New York you can find me on Twitter
and github and I have a data blog that I
don't update often enough so today I'm
gonna tell you a story about kind of our
our journey into doing deep learning
idea in Co so I'm going to start with
all the things that we tried to do to
avoid doing this and then I'll talk
about how we ended up having to go down
this route but before that I'd like to
explain what my company does and why it
exists so I'm gonna start off with a
stat for the data people in the room so
nearly 70% of women in the US are
plus-sized but they only represent 16%
of apparel spend and so what you see is
that we have a majority of the u.s. is
representing a minority of the spend and
you know some people think that this is
maybe due to lack of interest in fashion
by this segment but kind of the thesis
of Dia in Co is that this is a lack of
opportunity to participate in fashion
and so that's where we come in is to
help that opportunity so DN Co is the
leading digital first retailer dedicated
to serving women sizes 14 and up and we
do this through a particular business
model so the way our service works is
you sign up on our website fill out some
information about yourself so you tell
us what sorts of clothing you like your
size your height and other sorts of
relevant things in order for us to get
you clothing that you will like so the
way that we do that is we have a stylist
pick out five items of clothing that she
thinks that you will like these then get
sent to you in a box whatever you like
you keep and pay for whatever you don't
like you send back to us and you tell us
why you didn't like it and that helps us
to get better at making sure that each
time you're getting more and more of
what you like and so you can kind of
think of our stylists in some sense as
like the ultimate
recommendation system so you know what
is the ultimate recommendation system
it's somebody that it's like your friend
who knows you really well who's saying
hey like I think you're gonna love this
and so I think it things in terms of
recommendation systems I like I've done
a fair amount of these and so we can
think of this like a user to item
recommendation so given the user which
is our customer what sorts of items
might you like and we see recommendation
systems everywhere we can look at you
know the big tech companies of the day
and they all have recommendation systems
on their platform so Spotify will
recommend certain albums to you based on
what you've listened to given recent
shopping interests that you might have
had on Amazon they will know that you're
building a deep learning computer and
Netflix will you know sort these items
according to what they think that you
like and so from my side where do I come
in in this I work on the styling
algorithms team and it's my goal to
bring power to the stylist and so you
know I can ingest all this data I can
try to build a fancy recommendation
systems but that's not necessarily going
to help the stylist if they don't really
understand why the algorithm thinks that
these items are important and so kind of
our goal is to bring the power of all of
that data all of the fancy algorithms
and bring it to the stylist and so one
common way that you might see this done
is on these exact same platforms so if
you look on Spotify given a certain band
that you might have listened to it will
recommend other bands and it is telling
you that it is recommending this in
providing context around why these bands
are being recommended Amazon does the
same thing and Netflix as well and so
providing this context is really helpful
for understanding why items are being
recommended and then allowing the end
user to evaluate that and so we can
think of this as an item to item
recommendation so before we head user to
item this is item to item in the sense
that given this item here are other
similar items to that and then we can
provide context but you could argue that
similarity is subjective and it is
however you know I was tasked with this
this project at work and I was like no
no like like I got this because we see
classic item to item recommendations all
the time
Amazon tells you how they do it they say
customers who bought this item also
bought that other item and so they are
telling you you know this is the data
that they're using and this is how
they're building the recommendation and
so when I was tasked with this I was
like all right I got this like I have
this trick up my sleeve matrix
factorization I've used it a whole bunch
of times like we're gonna be good to go
and I was wrong however before we get to
that so what did I do I said all right
I've used matrix factorization before
recommendation systems and everything
else let me go grab this library
implicit which is open source it's on
github it's written in Python it's
actually easy to install which is
usually the hardest part of about using
libraries it's super fast because it's
written in scythe on its you know
running parallel and everything else and
it uses this industry standard algorithm
for building out recommendations for
implicit feedback and so I you know put
in all the data I train the model I got
could you know lost and everything else
and I was feeling good but I ran into
this issue and the issue was around
temporal separation and I'll explain
what these pictures mean in a second so
classically when we think of
recommendation systems oftentimes the
items live on for a long time in our
system so for example we still read
books that were written a hundred years
ago
however in fashion we have a bit of a
different situation in the sense that
our clothing has kind of a a short
half-life if you will and so we know
that you know fashion runs on trends and
everything else like that and so what
happened was when I trained this
algorithm was it would find that old
clothes were similar to old clothes and
so as an example Jerry Seinfeld existed
at the same point in time as The Fresh
Prince however I would argue that their
Styles are nothing similar but what my
algorithm found was that because you
know these these clothing existed at the
same point in time it was similar and so
these are bad recommendations and
but this is what we would want right we
would want to know that Jerry Seinfeld
from 15 or 20 years ago has a similar
fashion to this normcore Everleigh model
and so that's what we would like so I
said alright fine you know this didn't
work like I have other tricks up my
sleeve I'm going to use metadata about
the products to kind of connect the past
to the future so for example you can
imagine in our database that we have
information about this clothing so maybe
I know that the sneakers are that where
they're wearing sneakers they're white
sneakers they're wearing relaxed-fit
pants and everything else like that and
so maybe with this kind of external
information I could connect clothing
from the past to clothing from the
future so how do we do that again turn
to open source software there's this
library called light FM which is
excellent as well
it's Python easy to install superfast
and insight on you know it works in
parallel and everything else and the
nice thing about it is it allows you to
incorporate user and product metadata in
your matrix factorization
recommendations and so I'd use this
before so it's like all right cool I'll
throw this edit and everything will be
fine
but what I found was that if you you
know send garbage through a black box
then you get garbage out and I'll
explain that in a second so you know we
didn't get good results with that so I
said all right maybe we won't just look
at what people bought we will look at
what we sent them because we have denser
data around that and maybe we can learn
more that way maybe we can use user
metadata in addition to the product
metadata I tried a whole bunch of
combinations and nothing seemed to work
and I came to this conclusion that
generating high quality metadata is hard
and I kind of started to get
philosophical about this and wondered
like like what is metadata and like why
am i struggling with this problem and so
if we if we think about metadata a bit
it's what we're doing is we're taking
humans and asking them to try to guess
what they think is the relevant
information about some piece of data
guess what they think a machine would
think was relevant and so we're trying
to kind of encode this human knowledge
but we're doing it by hand and it's
fairly manual so there's a lot of room
for error and you know things can get
lost in translation but then also you
know maybe humans just aren't good at
guessing at what a machine would think
is relevant I don't know but then you
know I took a step back and I was
thinking about our clothing at work you
know and we can look at these different
shorts and arguably they might have
different metadata in our system
associated with them for example you can
see that they might have different
necklines they might have different
sleeve lengths possibly silhouettes and
things like that and so from the product
standpoint one you know from the
metadata standpoint one could argue that
these are these are different items of
clothing but at the same time I feel
like we can all just look at it and see
that they're fairly similar and so then
it was like oh we can look at it and we
can see like what else sees and that's
where we started to get into deep
learning and so I don't want to claim
that you know I did this alone there's
actually two excellent talks out there
one of them is the PI data talk from
other fashion companies that have kind
of gone down this route and started to
incorporate computer vision algorithms
into their systems so one is from these
great guys that list who also wrote the
light FM package and then there's also a
great talk from thread genius from the
New York City machine learning made up
list use the algorithm that I'll talk
about for finding duplicate items thread
genius was using this for given an image
can I match the clothing in that image
to a database of clothing and we use
this for something slightly different so
let me explain how this algorithm works
but it start with let's let's think
about what was the goal of this
algorithm so there's this paper from
2015 about facial recognition and you
wouldn't think that this was relevant to
product similarities but I'll get into
it so the the paper the goal of the
paper was threefold so one was they
wanted to be able to verify faces so
given this face
is this other picture a picture of the
same person here obviously the answer is
no the goal was also to look at facial
recognition so given this face which
person might we match to that face and
then lastly was around clustering so can
I find clusters of faces that tend to
look similar and Google actually
provided me with this which was which is
great I was able to search and other
people have found this and so it was
this last goal of the paper that seemed
relevant to two products so what I would
like to be able to do is take images of
different products and know that they
are roughly similar to each other such
that I could then cluster them find the
most similar items etc and so can we
take this face in that algorithm and use
it for something like product net so way
the algorithm works is a bit different
than kind of what at least I was used to
so I'm kind of used to the paradigm of a
like scikit-learn you have some design
matrix X you shove it through a model
and then you get some output Y and and
you can train this in a supervised
fashion but here we actually have to do
something a little bit different but
it's but it's pretty fun so the way this
algorithm works is you start with an
image of your product we'll call this an
anchor image you can send this through
some pre trained neural network and then
you know that neural network it's gonna
learn features of your images and
everything else and it's gonna pick out
edges and patterns and such and then at
the very end we're going to output a
vector and so the idea is that this
vector kind of is a compressed
representation of the image of our
product we will then take another image
of the exact same product so this will
be a positive example we send that image
through the same neural network and get
out a vector and so we know that the
anchor and the positive we know that
these are the same product we then take
a negative example so we grab an image
of a product that we know is different
send it through the same neural network
and output a vector and all the
algorithm tries to do once we've done
this is
we would like to move the image of the
same product close to that image of the
same product in this vector space and we
would like to move the image of the
other product away and so basically
we're just you know we're trying to
learn these vectors such that images of
the same product end up close to each
other and images of different products
end up far from each other and so what
this call what this is is this is like a
triplet sampling technique you have
these triplet loss functions which can
help you to do this but without math we
can what we're basically trying to do is
we're trying to minimize the distance
between the vectors representing images
of the same product and maximize the
distance between the vectors
representing images of different
products so I read through this whole
paper I was like alright let's try to do
this and so how do we end up programming
up this algorithm I had some
requirements one is I was totally new to
this whole area so I wanted something
that was easy to debug because I was
going to make mistakes we're also kind
of doing this weird way of building up
our training data and so we need some
easy way to sample due to some details
which if you're interested we can talk
about later
like there's details of the sampling
algorithm such that you actually have to
make some dynamic decisions during
sampling like while training and then
lastly I would like some pre trained
models so the original paper for this
was written by Google they're using many
orders of magnitude more data than we
have at our tiny company and so I don't
want to have to train things from
scratch so for this I chose to use PI
torch because it seemed to check off all
of these boxes so first of all PI torch
ended up being super easy to debug so
just to kind of orient yourselves at the
top we define a model which in this case
is a linear layer which is literally
just a single number this is just a toy
example we can define some data and we
can define like a target for that data
and then we can pass our data through
the model and generate a prediction and
what you see is we can kind of just like
write down our loss function by hand if
we want we run a backwards
to basically calculate the gradients and
then what we can do after this is we can
actually go through and print out the
gradients of our parameters and so I can
do this all in ipython I can kind of
like investigate what's going along on
along the way and it makes life pretty
easy it kind of feels like writing a
numpy the other nice thing is that there
are these kind of adjacent packages
which are part of this pie tour to
ecosystem that basically abstract away
lots of things so for example if you
know I'm dealing with images and so I'm
loading them off of the disk I have to
transform their size I might want to
normalize them and other sorts of things
and through torch vision you can
actually just kind of compose these
transformations and they've already
taken care of this for you loading
images off of a disk they actually have
a nice class for doing this for you and
then since we're loading multiple images
we're training and everything else maybe
we want to do this efficiently so we
want to do this in in parallel and so
you can use their data loaders for doing
that if you want to be fancy about your
sampling you can just write a subclass
of the of the datasets and then it makes
it pretty easy to do that as well the
other cool thing about pipe torches you
can make these dynamic dynamic decisions
so let's say I was feeling weird and I
wanted to find two models and every time
I shove my data through the model I then
or like every time I sample some data I
flip a coin and I say if it's heads I'm
gonna use this model if its tail's I'm
gonna use that model I don't know why
you don't ever want to do this but the
nice thing here is that I can just write
this like Python and do this should I
want to and then lastly for pre-trained
models these come prepackaged so I can
just import ResNet which is the neural
network that I ended up using for my
project you can import this you can
import it with all the weights that have
been trained on imagenet and then what
we're actually doing is we're
fine-tuning the model so what that means
is that we when we learn these vectors
that I was talking about we're not
actually changing the coroner all
Network we're only changing that last
layer we're only learning that last
layer where we want to
the vector representation and so doing
this ends up being being pretty easy to
do with these free trade networks so I
read the paper
I like learned enough Pytor to in order
to program this up and invariably you're
gonna end up having bugs in your code
and everything else and so I actually
took a page from this book they they
mention this in their talk where they
talk about trying to overfit and you
know I think you like if you can't over
fit on a very simple scenario then
there's probably something wrong with
your code and so what is the simplest
scenario that we can imagine let's take
two products and let's learn a vector
for them that is only 2 elements long so
we can think of this as two dimensions
where maybe the first element of that
vector is the X dimension the second
element is the Y direction and what this
allows us to do is it allows us to
visualize what's going on as we're
learning you can imagine if we had a
three element vector we could visualize
this in 3d and then if you had a four
element you you can't visualize that so
let's go with something simple so what
we're seeing here is I took multiple
images of two products and this is each
epoch in training and we are visualizing
what's happening for just learning these
two dimensions and we see that we're
nicely able to get them to separate
which was the goal of our algorithm so
it's like all right cool the other fun
thing that we can do is we can actually
so what is often done with these
algorithms is they normalize that vector
at the end and what this allows you to
do is basically it makes your Euclidean
distances fairly proportional to your
cosine distances and people often like
to use cosine similarity and so what
happens if you normalize a vector in two
dimensions you're actually just
confining these guys to live on a ring
if we normalized in three dimensions we
would be confining them to live in on a
surface and so it's cool we can do this
we can visualize it we can see that this
is still working next step all right we
can overfit
let's stop overfitting and let's
validate on test data so one of the
things that you can do is you can
actually turn this into like a giant
multi-class classification problem so
imagine I take
this image at the center and I kind of
look a certain distance from that image
in this vector space and I say that
everything that's within that distance
I'm gonna say is an image of something
that belongs to the same product and
everything outside of that distance is
from a different product we've now
turned this into kind of a binary
classification problem and then you can
basically plot ROC curves to see how
you're doing and what's cool is that
these algorithms are like super good and
so you end up plotting your ROC curves
on a log scale and feeling very good
about yourself compared to conventional
classification problems so cool we can
validate and everything else what's next
you know our loss functions have come
down we're feeling great I'd argue that
you're not quite ready because the
beauty of recommendations is that we can
actually explore them and look at them
to see if they just make some sense and
so what I did is I'll show you I built
this little flask app and all the flask
app does is you click on an image of a
product and it shows you what are the
most similar products based on their
distance in this vector space and what
are the least similar products and you
know you can scroll over you can see
what these similarity scores were and I
would argue you know that these other
products look fairly similar to that and
so it's like a nice sanity check to make
sure that everything is making sense and
what's fun is that you can then go
through and explore and so you can click
on one of the products and you can see
that one's recommendations and
everything else and so it's kind of its
I would argue that it's fun it's fun to
like travel through here and then also
to just you know do this for sanity
checks it's harder to do this with just
like a conventional logistic regression
like classification problem or something
like that so actually you know that code
is proprietary but I did this for a side
project a very similar idea of
visualizing these recommendations so if
you're interested you can go to this
link in the center and then I also have
the code for this up on github so fine
we we've done all this let's finally
build this thing and so you know
everything I've talked about so far has
taken up the majority of the talk but
what's
is that this is the part that ended up
taking the majority of the time when I
actually did this and so I just wanted
to share two pieces of I guess advice or
whatever of things that I learned along
the way so one of them is that I
mentioned that we're fine-tuning these
models and so this is an image of the
neural network that we're learning and
everything in this in this square the
the big bold square all of that doesn't
change every time we like iterate
through our data and and learn our
weights because we're just freezing that
and we're only fine-tuning that last
layer which is on the very right but it
turns out that everything in that box
that takes a really long time to compute
compared to that last layer and so one
nice way to speed things up is you just
cache the results of everything that's
in that box and when you're actually
going through training each epoch you
just learned that that final layer and
that saved me a whole bunch of time
after I realized to do this the other
area was around tests so one is to just
use real data when you're making your
tests there was a time when I tried to
just kind of make up fake matrices to
represent the images and things like
that and you just end up kind of writing
brittle tests and tying yourself into
knots in order to do that something else
was to not mock the i/o so you know
where I'm arranging images into
different folders on the disk and I have
to sample from these images and if I
want to split up it in the training and
test sets I have to move images to
different folders and so I started by
mocking all of this in my tests and that
wasn't good either
that was like a major pain and so you
know just using actual images like
committing them to github and using
these test image you know a couple
testament images and actually you know
testing moving things around in in your
directories is quite nice the other
thing is that regression test can help
so these deep learning like training
deep learning models you know we have we
have to sample we have to learn things
we have to write out outputs and things
like that and so having kind of these
end-to-end tests and and making sure
that they still behave as we say as we
change the code can be quite helpful but
really it's it's
super-hard so there's like IC blog posts
all the time about people you know
trying to talk about how to how to test
machine learning models and I think it's
like definitely still an open area of
investigation so once everything was
tested it was time to finally you know
serialize the results so that other
people could use this and so we tried to
take a very simple approach basically we
could take all the images for the same
product send them through this this
neural network that we learned and get
their output vectors and in you know
simplest way to represent a product in
this vector space is we just average all
their images together pi torch has a
nice dot numpy method which just
transforms your torch tensors into numpy
tensor numpy arrays and then we just
write this to s3 and so that was nice
and quick and then once everything was
written it was time to deploy so for
those of you who care about stacks we
deploy everything on docker we use AWS
batch for training our models you know
nightly training and things like that
everything is integrated with circle for
you know continuous integration and then
we serve up the similarities and the
recommendations via a sanic api which is
like an asynchronous Python API and so I
just wanted to close with this great
image that I found basically we tried
out a whole bunch of things a lot of
them didn't work and so kind of as a
last resort we ended up going down the
deep learning route which has been quite
fun like these frameworks are very
powerful and everything else but just
like with anything it's important to
keep in mind there's there's nothing
special about this and that you know
yeah
just beware and that's it thank you
[Applause]
yeah it's interesting I think that
sometimes works better with like classic
recommendation systems the problem here
is that I'm sorry the the question was
if we've looked at analogies and kind of
like outfit pairings to see if a belt
goes with a pair of jeans or something
like that I guess the problem is that
this algorithm is solely optimizing for
the the visual representation and and
the belts will never look anything like
the jeans probably and so it's gonna be
hard for it to learn that at least in
the way that we've set things up here
yeah so the question was around you know
in some ways like should we even be
recommending visually similar items if a
customer has already bought something
like that do they need another flowery
top and I think we have both types of
customers so we have some customers who
find something that they like and they
really want more of it and then we have
other customers who explicitly tell us
don't send me any more of that and so
we're trying to trying to satisfy both
that's a good question so the question
was around I guess dissimilar items so
when we looked at similar most
dissimilar to the original top we saw
black items but then when we reversed it
we didn't necessarily see the others I'm
actually not sure why that ends up
happening one thing I can comment on is
kind of the hierarchy that we've just
empirically observed that color seems to
be the
most important like aspect for
similarity and then it seems like kind
of pattern of the clothing is next and
then silhouette seems to pop out as the
as the third level in the hierarchy but
yeah not not exactly sure let me yeah
probably can't say exactly how many
items there are lots of them are not in
stock anymore
but definitely we have let's say let's
say thousands not millions yeah no so
actually that is the nice aspect of this
is that we're not dealing with scaling
issues like that so for example you know
there's like approximate nearest
neighbor methods for finding most
similar items and we actually we don't
have to deal with that because our data
smaller so we actually just load the
whole matrix in memory in the API and
then compute the like similarities
on-the-fly and it's fine which is it's
nice well less
so we try to shove everything we can
into it in the sense that so customers
fill out a profile with us so we can
turn what they've said into features we
have all sorts of information about our
products and then we know exactly what
our stylists have sent to customers and
then we know what they've purchased and
we also know how they've raided
everything and so we have with lots lots
to work off of yep yeah so so customers
do send then they send in their photos
they they show us their Pinterest boards
we have they they give us a lot of text
feedback and so a lot lots of features
to build which tends to take the
majority of the time yeah so the its
kind of interesting how you build up
these positive and negative examples so
the way the the way that it's programmed
up is we know what well we know the
positive examples and then we kind of
have to sample a negative example you
know so we know what images are images
of the same products and then we need to
pick some image of a different product
and so actually the way that this works
is it's called a hard- sampling so what
you do is you pick an image that is most
similar to your anchor image and so this
is kind of like the hardest one like the
one that's closest to it that we're
really trying to push away and so you
end up sampling from these hard
negatives on the fly as you're as you're
training and building up your batches to
train
yeah so thankfully we have this all in
our database that everything is kind of
catalogued into a hierarchy so we know
we know that like these are two images
of the same product that happened to
come in different colors and so what we
can do I mean you know we train off of
this but then also we can choose to
filter items for the front end I like in
order to do that so yeah yeah so that's
great question because as I said so the
question was around using grayscale
images instead of color and I mentioned
that color was kind of at the top of the
hierarchy for similarity and so that is
something that we would like to do
because then we could kind of tease out
silhouette and pattern and things like
that the only issue I guess well one is
that I haven't had time to do it but the
second one is that a lot of these pre
trained neural networks have been pre
trained based on three colors and so we
would kind of have to go in and modify
them and things like that and so but
it's yeah great point yeah good question
how did the humans feel about the
machines yeah so I think like we don't
we don't tell them what to do you know
that like I feel good about the
algorithms that I've written but I don't
feel good enough that I can interpret
everything that a customer is telling us
so as a human Ken and so like that is
really why you know the goal of this
isn't to let's say limit what they're
seeing or anything else it's really to
just tell them this is why the machine
thinks this might be relevant and then
use your human judgement and then
ideally once they've used their human
judgement we can then feed that back in
to then better optimizer recommendations
and so we try to you know keep things
copacetic and everything else
yeah yeah there they're excited about it
because they want to know like they like
right now they would have to manually
search through to find out other similar
products and this can help to save them
time and you know help them so yeah yeah
so the question is about the ROC curves
and if we're if we're kind of optimizing
for items that should look similar or
are we just looking like looking for
items that truly are the exact same item
or images that are truly of the exact
same item and it's the latter because
the the original way the algorithm was
written was really for facial
recognition and so like if you ever like
going dear if anybody uses google photos
you can click the search bar and it'll
actually show you that they've already
grouped you and all of your friendss
images together in their database or
Facebook right they they suggest who to
tag in this image and so that's really
the goal is being perfect for us like
that's not what we're optimizing for
because we want to find other similar
items but the nice thing is that if we
if we optimize this algorithm we kind of
get out those similarities for free
yeah so the question was around I guess
the fact that we're using other vendors
who have trained a larger data sets and
I guess there's a question around should
we should we be using that maybe we do
things ourselves or there's I guess you
could go all the way to like the the API
is that these services provide to really
not have to do anything on your side
this feels like kind of a nice middle
ground between all of that I guess you
know it's true that we don't we don't
really necessarily want to spend the
time and the money to train these models
ourselves and as far as we know this is
this is okay if we use these pre trained
models so I guess why not it is true
that if they were to turn off the spigot
and people stopped to stop and releasing
these things then we would have to deal
with that but yeah yeah yeah so the
question was around if we've tried to
learn I guess where the mannequin is in
the image in order to kind of let's say
classify our products into short sleeve
long sleeves and things like that so we
actually record this data ourselves
anyway it's kind of out of laziness or
the power of deep learning that we could
just shove images with the mannequin
through and we get reasonable results
out so we do tend to find that like
sleeve length tends to be like one of
the aspects that the model learns for
similarity but I think like an exciting
like Avenue to go down would be because
we have this expert knowledge that we
know that this is a short slave top you
can imagine we we use this algorithm to
learn visually similar items and then we
kind of rank them afterwards based on
our expert knowledge so we could use the
other features that we have in there to
then let's say either filter so to just
so short sleeve or we are keeping track
of what everybody's clicking on and we
could actually run a learning to
ranked model using that expert
information afterwards TBD
great it's like lunchtime so y'all go
thank you
[Applause]